c'est un genre de rodéo sur les
déferlantes au beau milieu de la mer
d'iroise là où les vagues de
l'atlantique terminent leur course folle
en se mélangeant au courant de marée
[Applaudissements]
armé d'un simple fil de pêche et de
quelques leurres les marins de ce far
west bretons risquent leur peau pour
l'un des poissons les plus recherchés
des côtes françaises
le bar
le temps d'une marée nous avons suivi
deux pêcheurs plutôt du genre téméraires
jean marc guilcher est aux commandes de
ce qu'il appelle son char d'assaut
quand à mick rosen ne vous fiez pas aux
apparences il n'a pas sa langue dans sa
poche
lorsque les choses tournent mal
tous les deux ils sont originaires de
l'île de sein et chacun dans leur style
il chevauche leurs montures surpuissante
pour affronter une mer démontée
l'un pêche du côté de ouessant l'autre
au large de l'île de sein
[Musique]
merde
à l'aller on est bien
même pas un bar jean louis est une
solution avancée année dus à l'eau pour
commencer à savoir lequel qui empêche de
chez nous sommes à la fin du mois d'août
il est 7 heures du matin mik
le patron d'art flamen a déjà filé ces
lignes dans les remous de la chaussée
d'art mais non loin de l'île de sein
pour lui cette journée commence très mal
en faire carrément de temps il a des
parents
étant de bâton est remplie bas il est
brutalement
l'avion
vraiment je peux faire éjecter salue les
cas où il fait mauvais pour tout le
temps on regarde autour de toi
non je pense
alors que mick désespère que les
courants tourner à son avantage
nous mettons le cap sur l'île d'ouessant
au pied du phare du créac'h sur son
bateau la chimère jean-marc à tort
encore l'arrivée en masse des fous de
bassan l'arrivée de ces oiseaux marins
est le premier signal pour commencer les
hostilités
la chaussée de keller est encore plus
mal pavée que le raz de sein c'est un
vrai champ de mines
c'est précis aux affaires depuis son
arrivée
à abattre d'audierne adhésion à l'onu
avant ici et par la loi
je vais garçons passant par ici
ce montant
quand je rentre j'appelle souvent
téléphone mamadou keïta
je passe les si je raccroche
jeudi soir encore papa vous
pacy
[Musique]
et attention à toi l'enjeu
laisse tomber en travers
c'est le moment qui est le plus
de plus ajouté
jean-marc se laisse tomber dans la
marmite autrement dit il dirige son
bateau dans une mer en ébullition car
c'est là dans les cuves que le bar bien
se nourrir de maquereaux
non
[Musique]
mais attention ici plus qu'ailleurs ce
sont les mouvements de la mer qui
commande
et la moindre erreur peut être fatale
écoute là pour éviter de se prendre par
le travers lâcher ce nul doute dedans et
on a bien chargé là quand même
on n'ira pas plus bas
et ça a mordu l'un
ça demande beaucoup d'efforts au bateau
est ce qu'il pilote pour avoir un
poisson 12 euros ou 13 euros le kilo
pour tellement d'efforts quand tu sais
qu'après en poissonnerie c'est 30 euros
le kilo ça paraît un peu dérisoire de
vouloir gagner sa vie en tenant un fil
au bout de sa main mais mais pourquoi
pas je sais pas c'était l'avenir on va
nous pondre une pêche douce et en fin de
compte de morts que ce qui veut mordre
[Musique]
je
alors que jean marc est en train de
remplir ses caisses de poisson allons
voir ce qui se passe du côté de la
chaussée d'armen à l'île de sein
il est 11 heures la force du courant a
baissé ce qui est plutôt bon signe pour
mika
et vous allez passer ou nous on évite
d'aller nous on évite d'aller là vous
allez passer dessus est passé par mois
le poisson est à cette place pour pêcher
une bonne ailleurs ouais mais ça fait
rien tu vas tomber ou et le poisson
c'est pas bon simon ammann qui devait
l'amener là bas web monde sur moi
j'avais le mal il l'a
s'il ya bien une chose que mick déteste
ce sont les plaisanciers qui viennent
tenter leur chance sans savoir qu'en
naviguant n'importe où il éloigne les
bancs de bach la journée avait mal
commencé pour lui
mais au bout du compte le poisson
commence à mordre et plutôt bien
[Musique]
oh
merde j'ai balancé le ballon au raf
vaches tout va mal léna mignon tout
aussi à dubai à deux ou trois bateaux
note que ça oui y'a trop bizarre aussi
[Musique]
il est midi et la mer est à nouveau en
train de forcir
à ouessant jean-marc sa mise à l'abri
le stif le stif du chimère oui le stif
c'est le chimères agents pu avoir une
idée du temps qu'ils annoncent toujours
là tout radar du stiff à ouessant
réguler le trafic des cargos qui entrent
ou qui sortent de la manche mais les
agents des affaires maritimes ont
toujours un oeil sur ce qui se passe en
contrebas dans la chaussette keller
le stif est donc une vigie précieuse en
cas d'accident
bon c'est pas ce qui va se passer on
subit en fin de compte un mois j'ai
souvenir d'un gars qui me demandaient
combien il fallait dans ma journée pour
gagner ma vie de lait bio gab a répondu
que je prenais que ce qu'on me donnait
de toute façon donc
donc je trouve ça c'est ce qui fait le
charme de ce métier là aussi
quelques minutes plus tard les fous de
bassan sont de retour sur la zone de
pêche
ils commencent leur chasse
[Musique]
avec les énormes déferlante les pêcheurs
ne sont plus très nombreux sur l'eau
pour les dernières minutes de pêche tous
les coups sont permis certains
n'hésitent pas à passer sur la ligne d
autres c'est le jeu
[Musique]
les ligneurs se font la guerre mais en
cas d'accident cas d'homme à la mer
ils seront tous solidaires car ces
marins du bout de la bretagne ont tous
en tête à un ami disparu
on a nos ventres là parce qu'on sait pas
trop ce qu'on va faire dans la saison là
on est sur la fin on sait que c'est la
période de mauvais ton c'est que donc
bon on fait encore plus attention parce
qu'on a envie de la finir la saison à
quinze 15 jours ou trois semaines près
en fait on fait quand même attention
qu'on sait c'est souvent sortant de là
tu as les genoux qui tremblent on rigole
pas tous des lourds
en moins d'une demi-heure et jean-marc
remonte des dizaines de bars plus gros
les uns que les autres
[Applaudissements]
le meilleur pour la fin
moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour soi
sont là en tout cas c'est pas quand il
voit dans ça dans ta caisse là c'est
malheureux ce qui lui arrive mais bon
ben je sais pas comment je pourrais le
décrire
c'est pas un chasseur comme nous enfin
jeu
le comparait souvent
un pêcheur patois il est mal vieilli
fait ça pour se nourrir enfin il vient
là toi comme nous un il nourrit en fin
de compte il est 13 heures jean marc
rejoint milk au large de l'île de sein
ces gens là oui oui tu es là moi je te
vois pas j'arrive la hâte et à l'appui
avant tu arrives ou bien à ok ok très
bien et 10 mois
il faut construire parce que sinon on va
on va louper la bombe donc tu as
beaucoup embarqué dans d'accord d'accord
très bien ok parce que là on est à la
bourre il est web - car nous il faut
qu'on soit avant 15h45 faut que ce soit
dans une heure à l'audience
la pêche est terminée commence alors une
autre course contre la montre les deux
pêcheurs de l'île de sein ne veulent
surtout pas rater la vente du jour
et sakho au large de l'île de sein
jean-marc récupère la cargaison de milk
dans le monde des ligneurs l'amitié
rares j'aime et mick et jean-marc se
connaissent depuis longtemps leur père
ses péchés déjà ensemble
il ya des tories
cap sur la criée d'audierne le principal
port de débarquement du bar de ligne
jean marc guilcher fait tout ce qu'il
peut pour arriver à temps afin d'obtenir
un bon prix
il m'a dit ça fait 8
[Musique]
c'est marie carré
via pas beaucoup de bars sur la criée y
aura peut-être du prix verra bien
alors le verdict
non je dirais pas je dirai pas combien
on a péché mais bon c'est bien c'est
bien pour qu'on croie jours de pêche
n'est pas mal
secret on va dire on va dire ça comme ça
à la fin de cette marée micky le patron
d'art flamen aura pêché 80 kg de bach
jean-marc le patron de chimères
préfèrent se taire
il garde ses secrets et il a raison il
faut dire que la pêche au bar de ligne
les places sont très chères les zones de
capture rétrécissent à vue d'oeil chaque
année alors de plus en plus les ligneurs
professionnels flirte avec les limites
du raisonnable mais c'est ainsi qu'ils
gagnent leur vie